um
this week as a 30 year old man azim
rafiq shared everything about how racism
at yorkshire county cricket club
destroyed his life
but the 19 year old azeem rafiq sent
racist messages himself
in a chat with another cricketer at
javid they discussed how a friend was
mean with money
in one javid said of the friend he will
not pay watch he's going to be like i
left my card at home
azim rafiq he is a jew probs go after my
seconds again
atik javid i know
that is wrong gonna get ripped for that
mate azeem rafiq proper ripped bro how
wrong is that only jews do that sort of
in response azeem rafiq said
i have absolutely no excuses i'm ashamed
of this exchange and have now deleted so
as not to cause further offence i was 19
at the time and i hope and believe i'm a
different person today
i'm incredibly angry at myself and i
apologize to the jewish community and
everyone who is rightly offended by this
now i think that azeem has recognized
the hurt
that these stereotypes and the uh you
know pronouncing these stereotypes has
caused and will cause to the jewish
community
but i think he's also recognized that
this behavior is unacceptable he's
apologized and i think he has understood
that this is not the way that people
should be behaving
while embarrassing for rafiq it also
makes his point about how headingly at
the time was a place where
discrimination and racism was just
normal
obviously he will regret
desperately regret what he said all
those years ago
it does not make it right racism
in any color shape or form
does not work it's just not right it's
just not crooked
this is a huge moment for cricket
tomorrow senior figures at the 18 county
clubs will meet at the oval in london to
thrash out with the england and wales
cricket board what needs to change
we've heard about a 12-point plan that
counties are going to have to put in
place to try and increase representation
um around the country and that there are
going to be financial penalties this is
the first time where actually there are
going to be implications this is why
it's kind of ignited because initially
yorkshire while acknowledging that there
was there were racist remarks nothing
was going to happen nobody was going to
be held accountable
azeem rafiq knows that his own past
mistakes will be used to discredit him
creating change
is rarely an easy process